did you get the braces guards to treat
you with respect
you're in prison and you said I will
only respond to the name Mandela or mr.
Mandela you must fight the battle for
dignity on the very first day you go to
jail
really and that's what we did we put our
foot down and insisted in being
respected even though were prisoners and
we thought what a successor to that - it
could not affect a peaceful
transformation without talking to our
enemy addressing their fears as a
minority and the trauma of loss in power
it was under those circumstances that
have reconciliation to place in South
Africa we would therefore expect their
role in majority to take the initiative
to ensure that the feelings of that
minority are addressed and that her
programs of upliftment are made
available to them
you just watched two amazing clips from
Nelson Mandela take the next three
minutes and sit quietly to think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]